all right so we're talking about
friendship and look see tonight
Aristotle's naked Makena makes a little
work
we're done with various levels for our
studying and we're gonna keep talking
about airsoft over the course of the
semester because now we've looked at two
major reduce I will say this person is
different from Aristotle and Plato in
this way
they're like them this way I also have
this this sort of scheme up here and you
notice it's sort of a crime line right
through your life yeah
my life yeah I want you to think about
this over the course of your life you
have progressed from elementary school
to middle school to high school without
college and you've been in college here
for three or four years somebody who are
seniors you're graduating this year so
our juniors here yeah and what I want
you to think about you can't friends at
each point right you had friends in
elementary school how many of those
friends did you carry forth into middle
school the answers are going to be
different for refreezes right because
some of you you went to a middle school
and most of the kids from your
elementary school didn't go then so that
makes it tougher but then you also even
those of you who did sort of go in a
cohort and new everybody into middle
school to change friends why did that
happen
and the answer at Mike from elementary
school to middle school the answer why
that happened would be a bit different
than the trans
high school because you're at different
stages in here in their maturation the
stuff that matters to you as an
elementary students
for the most part doesn't matter to you
quite as much in high school a new
things that come to matter to you much
more and then you probably well you know
this is your first break of the year
remember back to years ago when you were
freshmen here or three years ago it was
to our seniors and your first fall break
most of you more or less hopefully you
know within 3-4 hours a year you know
some people are from and that was your
first time coming home from college and
you probably already ended notice that
some of them some of your friends you
were no longer interested in hanging out
but you no longer can function with this
ring true to you
somebody's experienced some of your
friends you may have actually gotten
closer
as a result but some of them you love
behind the same thing that's going to
happen as you go some of you are going
to grad school you're going on a
professional schools like law school or
medical school not everybody from Marist
is going there those of you who are
going into a career you may put people
in your workplace but you're going to
get to know a whole bunch of other
people and odds are your generation your
at least five different career changes
over the course of your your life that's
the job these days where you're not just
you know changing from one company to
another you're actually changing what
you do that's why it's so important that
you have these you know skills that you
learned say in philosophy classes being
able to think things out right because
whatever you're trained for right now
that may not existent in ten years
definite meds for all too many doctors
but the specific things that you're
training her they may change very
considerably
what else were interested in the answer
is stuff we're interested in friendship
so think at each course in your
experience Aristotle is all about using
your experience to make sense of the
world how many friends who've left
behind how many people that you have a
relationship with that you no longer
have you no longer have a relationship
there's probably quite a few right
myself I've been very bad about this
I have only one friend that I stayed in
touch with consistently since high
school where for me in high school was
almost 25 years ago
we were part of a circle of friends this
is familiar to you - you have a group of
friends that you hang out with but then
everybody ended up going their separate
ways where they died someone some of our
transactional died you know doing well
this this can be your experience
elementary school I didn't keep in touch
with anybody from elementary school once
I was in college I think I kept in touch
with one person from my elementary
school when I was in high school middle
school that's about it now I have a
weird yeah because I went to a public
elementary school and then I went to a
private middle school grid see you then
very smart very rich to get in and the
two didn't go to mix Catholic High
School so not a lot of people you know
moving through that but still I didn't
keep in touch with people and then I've
moved you know lots of times I I went to
college in Wisconsin in Sheboygan
Wisconsin yeah that was friends with a
lot of people and they've had a very
active social life forever
you got their phone numbers and their
addresses and then I went down to
Milwaukee and worked for a year and went
off to Europe for a little while and how
many of them do you think they actually
stayed in five or six yeah by the time
that I was in grad school down in
Illinois and that was for about seven
years I lost touch with thumbs
deprivation from college just in college
not from like high school or else fall
in college and then I moved to Indiana
and I started my first job my first
major job
and then I lost touch with also people
from grad school you know I meet other
people here at their conferences or
fellowships things like that
and you dance here contact us now you
know I moved down to Fayetteville State
University and did I follow up a lot of
the friendships I had another places you
not changed that for me
thanks bar there's a Facebook and then
you go online and you guys will never
actually experience this because your
generation has grown up in facebook how
many of you use Facebook so probably
about nineteen ninety five years of the
class how long have you guys been on
Facebook following in the Edit account
since freshman in high school right
cottage freshman your college world the
rest of you seen here the high school
sophomore year we relative one for seven
years so that's somewhere in high school
right because you're a junior okay so
you know parents are kind of a
restrictor on that right you know a lot
of parents who don't let their kids have
Facebook
age which is really you know it was not
the answer
prevalence is this people often so you
guys are never going to experience this
leaving all these people behind and
being out of touch and really having no
way other than you know doing like some
extensive research of fighting now if
you lost them for the Fremen
just look about my facebook there down
out there that probably on LinkedIn
right or some other some other social
networks that you guys use that and we
you know Jen acts forty year olds don't
use those change like this Facebook is
here to stay and Facebook is is where
you carry it out a good deal of your
friendship right that Facebook has
transformed this sort of stuff we're
gonna study with Aristotle it's allowed
one factor to be taken out of the
equation so actually look that's a good
jumping-off language so Aristotle says
that certain things are required for
friendship what does he think is a
actually required one of the things that
he says you have to have is spending
time together now that's hard to do when
you're on distances and if you have
long-distance relationships we have one
mr. Dugan how to cope what's that like
doesn't worry yeah it's very tough fur
why what else can you say about it you
have to deliberately make time for
things something you just say hey let's
go grab dinner you have actually plans
for like Saturday and then when you're
when you are together there's this
pressure to we only have you know one
week let's really make this week great
did you guys have that going on as well
yeah distance is an issue
Aristotle actually says there's distance
and timing these are factors Aristotle
says at one point in this this famous
quote that in order to become friends
with so many truly friends with somebody
you have to eat a bear a little salt
together
now it doesn't mean they can actually
sit down and scoop salt so good we would
like salty things but nobody likes salt
that much I hope because what he means
is you know each meal you know you
sprinkle a little bit of salt on your
cooks generally
they will assault their own food so to
eat a barrel full of salt together means
that you are with that person
continuously for a sustained period of
time eating with people is one of the
ways we become practices being in
classes so time is a factor distance is
a factor Facebook and other social media
the whole web 2.0 phenomena allows us to
overcome distance and even to some
degree time to doesn't because if your
friend is interacting with you think
about the way that interactions work in
facebook if you want to talk to somebody
directly in real time what do you have
to do what's up you have time well what
else has to happen though that's what
you do on your app they have to be if
you want to talk in real time what
function to use Facebook just going them
all and write something a message okay
Chandler right she had his real time but
you can do it another things you can do
it to Google as a matter of fact my
fiancee and I our our relationship which
in a way started 25 years ago because
they met in high school when we were
first getting back in touch we used
Google Chat because you could you know
go back and forth line up the line
there's four hours all right when you're
chatting with somebody time can pass
pretty quickly what is it then when
somebody writes on your wall that's not
real time is it they can't feel like you
know you write so you put a status
update and they say something in
response a couple hours later you look
at your Facebook oh you write something
in response and then they write
something in response a couple minutes
later a couple more hours pass but if
this time doesn't actually exist
isn't that Facebook or other forms of
social media it allows us to overcome
these factors which in a way allows us
to become friends and maintain krabs
more easily you guys are in a better
position than lazy people like I have
you know Facebook is great for those who
wouldn't make the effort to write a
letter I'm terrible promising to write
people letters than that even even I
don't follow up I go to conferences and
to meet people and common interest
they've written some things about Plato
and then do you email you can give them
your card they give you your card you
guys are good to start experiencing
that's pretty
to whatever field you're going just
because you gave somebody your card that
doesn't mean that you actually have a
relationship I go again
the Facebook allows that late didn't
another great example too because when
the end result was talking about
friendships he's not just talking about
the people that you really love spending
time with all the time
you know your chums from high school or
something like that he's also talking
about professional relationships and
what's linked it how many of you're on
LinkedIn now okay so about a quarter of
the class you should probably all be on
LinkedIn now because you're juniors and
seniors
yeah and it's important for a networking
and what actually gets you jobs in a lot
of cases who you know who can send you
information and so you probably do want
to get LinkedIn okay so that's that's
all sort of just background stuff trying
to set the stage what does the Aristotle
actually say about friendship
besides time space well those why do we
care about friendship what makes it
valuable why do we need friends
so well yeah so um should we express
that there's little talks about it as
friends and when you're talking about
this sort of as companionship what's the
opposite of that being being lonely
being on your own and some people very
few people like being totally long well
kid yes
Aristotle is very realistic he thinks
that we need friends that have security
and that's okay
I mean that we often think of that as we
shouldn't be friends with somebody for
that reason but if you don't think you
realize especially as you go through
crises that's when you actually do find
out who your real friends are because
real friends have your back and real
friends when you bring up a problem with
them they don't say I talked with you
about that so you know you go through a
death you go through Wars you know major
illness we go through a change in job or
wealth or something like that that shows
and Aristotle says you know even if even
if things really go south at least a
good friend is there at your toilet you
breathe let's say someone who kind of
finds someone to confide in the
companionship and say and we know we we
feel too private if we don't have if we
have nobody to talk to which is the case
for many people when you feel bad you
know we can't actually enjoy the good
life without that we also need for
grounds where you gonna say before you
throw some more stutters and say
something along the security don't
haven't you just meet some friends that
help you out which is you know we live
in this society and you can't not have
somebody there people that assist you
yeah since then even hopes with
happiness still did you get a certain
gravity yeah that's where we get to the
next one
Aristotle says that so happiness is like
the virtuous sentiment doing doing good
things you gotta have somebody to do
good things to write or are you just
gonna walk down the street and then find
some people hey I'm gonna be generous
that wouldn't actually be generous being
generous to your friends is is important
and family would be included in that
you know cuz family and friends actually
for Aristotle overlap quite a bit and
this is kind of interest so we need
friends in part for what they provide us
we also need threads for what they allow
us to provide them that's the kind of
social animals that we are we're needed
in a couple different ways we're not
just needed that we need to take from
other people
we're needy and that in order to feel
okay in order to really have a good life
we need other people that we can give to
and we need to have a personal
connection to them this is why you know
you see those the ads for Save the
Children and all that that's why they
have that component of the kid writing a
letter back so that the relationship can
develop
I'll actually tell you kind of an
interesting story about the prison stuff
you know some people have to learn how
to be good friends have to learn how to
have relationships with other people and
a lot of the guys that it's one of the
prison were kind of deficient that way
one of the best things that Indiana has
and I think a lot of other states campus
as well is at least an indiana state
prison the prisoners adopt cats they can
adopt cats that would otherwise be put
to sleep
from the Amane society so you know it
keeps the key on alive which is good and
these you know a picture these big guys
want you know worked out a lot of time
covered with tattoos you know wearing
prison white and khaki and sitting in
their cell petting a kid which they
raised and they know through that they
better they better stay on their good
behavior because if they screw up that
cat gets taken away from them and the
cats are allowed to roll them through
the entire prison I think the prison
likes it a park is Indiana State Prison
was the oldest one at the end
Indiana goes back to like the 1840s and
there were rats and mice and stuff like
that of the cat's home take care of that
as well but those cats roaming
throughout the entire prison nobody here
itself because anybody who had actually
heard a cat
you know a prisoner that it's not the
guards you would do anything it's the
other prisoners because they recognize
in that camp honorable creature and many
of them form strong connections with
these these creatures for a lot of these
guys it's the first time within their
life that they have something in a
fairly controlled environment that they
can learn how to love and develop a
certain kind of friendship
which that can be part of training for
how to you know move to better
statements instead it's a great thing
matter of fact one of the guys I used to
work with these to be my tutor if you
watching us at NBC lock up and I could
watch that show there's actually an
episode buddy of adopting his camp and
what goes on under the prison with these
cats barren ground and now he was a much
more advanced than the other guys
emotionally it's part of how he became
my tutor and how we became friends
ourselves but you know he he and I
talked quite a bit about this phenomenon
about the prison cats and what's going
on there it's not just that somebody
needs a warm body to curl up with them
they needed somebody to do good to
that's a part of friendship that's part
of relationships maybe not to start
right when you were little babies were
you looking for somebody to do good to
you do the opposite that became
something important to you so get rid of
all real issues let's look at what's
required for pressure so Aristotle says
that you need to spend time
person we need to be with them
physically in in space for a while what
else is involved in friendship you have
to have a certain kind of feeling
towards them right you have to delight
in the person now this could be a lot of
different ways he's very realistic about
what with this delighted to be finding
somebody do you like to have sex with
that's a kind of delighting in them all
right you made to test them otherwise
but you enjoy having sex with them
that's a kind of friendship Marysol I'm
very you know not a very lasting kind of
friendship not the paradigm but it's
okay
your business partner why are you
business partners to somebody now
because you want it to work with them
the guys that you're you're with on the
team maybe you're not friends maybe you
can actually eat some of them there's
like sports teams that I don't know but
most of them you have some sort of kind
of thing that you're working towards and
you actually do enjoy their company for
the most part for the most part that's
delighting them some of the people that
you've held on to his friends that
you're gonna when you guys go home on
break you're gonna see probably before
you do that those are people you delight
in so there has to be that feeling if
you also like nearest level says you
have to wish well for the other person
you have to want the other person to do
well and not for the sake of you know
something else but for their own sake
again this is the paradigm this is
for example and it has to be mutual can
you be in you actually in aerosol sense
be friends with somebody who doesn't
want to be friends with you can't you
can be friendly towards them but you
can't be friends you can't have a
friendship with somebody who actually
doesn't want to be friends with you who
doesn't desire good for you this is
where we're gonna get some really
interesting stuff before we do that he
talks about three kinds of friendship
and he says if we want to think about
the kinds of friendship we have to think
about the reasons why people are friends
with each other what they get from each
other what they are enjoying or
delighting it what does he say that what
kinds of questions either very good
yeah you know I think a lot in our
society we walk wouldn't call those
people friends we do say about using
friends and you know that person's just
friends with them tend to get something
but Aristotle that would even extend
this to like business associates your
co-workers people like that or maybe
teammates that you don't like but but
you need somebody to pick for you you
know you know pass the ball of you
trying to think of what other examples
would relate to people the athletes in
our class with passing go for all the
soccer guys to do an assist any people
you guys offense or defense as a soccer
players in here well they were relying
on you to actually keep you know their
their work from not going to - no I by
keeping the other guys I'm scoring a
goal so you get the idea
there are friendships and there are
friendships of utility their friendships
of usefulness or somebody is getting
something from somebody else what what
other kinds are there
what's a higher more inclusive
approaches very good I mean the people
that you you still hang out with from
high school it's not because there
business connections that they're gonna
set you up with a job maybe up to maybe
a few of our that way or because they
throw great parties and you want to go
and get the free food and drink you know
that would just be silly there are
people that you want to hang out with
because they're they're pleasant
you're like their sense of humor you
watch the same kind of movies together
you enjoy doing pickup sports with them
the people what other ways should have a
lot more examples should but you guys
can think of examples I mean what what
are other things that people do together
that are their pleasant I'm a bad
example because you know what I did most
of college other than studying was
hanging out at bars playing in begins
music and working out and having a lot
of relationships that was very good
example you know what do you guys do
with your friends my friends like
working on cars and stuff so yeah
finding some sort of common activity
working on cars you can do that always
something going wrong with some
something's car isn't you'll always have
some kind of thing to do watching the
game you know that's one that's easy for
me to relate
what else what else people do it
together that's that's that's fine play
video games yeah video games probably
consumes a lot yeah some kind of like
actually yeah a lot of are talking to
each other I think would be a matter of
a pleasure
it may not be particularly fine but you
enjoy it right there you know I have
some relatives when I talk to them I'm
not looking for them to enlighten me
oh that's a good example yeah traveling
together you know Aristotle says that
another thing that's important for
friendship is having common experiences
common interests of davin traveler he is
a great way to do that because you're
trying all sorts of new things you have
you can compare your reactions all these
sorts of things that that go into why
we're friends with people can come to
play in that as well so yeah that's a
big example that's funny what's the
third that about you
this is this may be a little harder
together virtue now Aristotle can go
back and forth of them is that one point
he talks about this as if this is
extremely rare this is the pyridine this
is where you like the person genuinely
for who they are because you find their
character attractive you think that
they're a good person and he says these
kinds of friendships you know are
actually kind of rare but then in other
places you talks as if this is more
common now these are three different
reasons why you could like somebody
you'd get something from them something
that may not be in fact pleasure could
be money could be prestige could be a
job it could be all sorts of things
could be that you actually enjoy
spending time with them or it could be
that you genuinely think that
as a good person you like being with
them for that reason now notice that
this walking includes this Pleasant
trans artifact useful friends they're
useful for giving you pleasure right you
could talk about using down and friends
who are friends because of virtue or
because they're genuinely good people I
mean they clicked kind of that way that
will be pleasant but being being good is
unpleasant to you you're not good or I
guess not
alright there's something wrong if if
doing the right thing to you is is not
enjoyable that something somewhere has
gone haywire and you're not yet virtuous
you might be countenance remember we
talked about this last time you may be
forcing yourself to do the thing that's
better than not doing a good thing but
it's not yet enjoying it and so people
who are genuinely good and who like each
other's characters they will find each
other's company pluses very positive
action they may have to challenge each
other
right of thing they may have arguments
maybe they're not entirely here's a
great example you know because I never
explain these to you before where you
know where are my vices if I have vices
which I probably do two main ones that I
have problems with that we've looked at
so far moderation so I got to be the
size eating too much exercising what I
should you know that sort of thing and
anger managing anger what happens when
you put two people two friends who both
manage anger poorly together but also
actually hold each other nice standards
what happens in situations like for my
friends had a big anger they we actually
got no fistfight at once but the next
morning we're hanging out BSA and stuff
like that yeah if you know I give you
whole other people to high standards and
into the friendship over to you you hold
yourself to high standards you're front
of all due to high standards and then
vice versa and you tend to you know
remember when we talk about here you
know anger sort of is sort of like the
servant that here's a few things that
run so often starts doing so you're
probably going to get in fights with
them so getting in fights is not
necessarily a sign that you know you
don't crash you know it's a sign that
you have some stuff to work on you know
your anger then if you're getting in
fights because you want to use the other
person and they're not letting them use
them that's a whole different ball game
isn't this where you're getting in a
fight with somebody because your
friendship was based totally on pleasure
and now you're not getting the pleasure
that you want
now you don't like them anymore they
would still want you to hang out with
them that's very different than this and
you know a good good friendships are
also going to include usefulness
good friends are good to each other you
do good things for each other friend I
mentioned you know from high school she
is in many ways helped me just by the
way he acts understand what Aristotle
was talking about just by the way he
behaves not realizing he said he's not a
philosopher he's a businessman computer
but he's a good friend he's a genuinely
good guy know what kind of friendship
spit into this well I guess that
business associations fit into this all
right what about your romantic love
interests this is something that
Aristotle didn't devote an awful lot of
attention to because he was more
interested in and you know philosophical
pursuits and the Greeks didn't really
value the the you know male-female
relationship as highly as we do in our
society and if you read this stuff you
also notice he doesn't want that right
you guys notice that from here he treats
women as if they're inferior men as if
they're superior let's say we put all
that stuff aside let's say we bring
heiress level off the date of 2000 I
think a lot of you your idea of the good
life is going to include some sort of
person
or maybe not maybe you just have a maybe
you're only interested in sex then
that's a matter of club sugar I have sex
is pleasurable should be if it's not
they're doing something wrong right and
there's all sorts of guides for that
sites that you can look at to help you
out with your videos I think probably
courses you could take you know at some
university that would probably help you
with that right they are somewhat same
you know we enjoy sex because sex is
enjoyable that is there's a pleasure
just like eating is a pleasure
drinking is a pleasure people who are
involved with each other in a
relationship they hook up and they're
gonna have sex with each other they like
the way each other looks maybe they you
know make me
he makes me laugh you know that sort of
thing they hook up with each other now
they're going to make a relationship out
of it often that doesn't work right one
of the reasons as well doesn't work is
because they think that they're having
this sort of thing because in our
society we come we often pressure
ourselves to be having this kind of
relationship what is actually this
calculation yeah having you know wrong
ideas about what you're actually
involved in is a good way to go go
astray these kind of relationships are
not lasting Aristotle says because as
soon as the other person stops being
pleasant stops giving pleasure the
relationship is going to break out
that's why and I'm not talking about sex
now at this point
really unusual sex life that's why
you're not friends with all of your
middle school or high school transit
either they've being Pleasant you guys
enjoy the same things you enjoy company
before maybe you're not interested in
the same things as they you and they
were interested them if that's the case
well let's take traveling for example
you know a lot of people this is the
time for you guys to travel actually
bother you while you're unattached the
most part while you're young so you can
go up and down the hills and you know
show up stuff all over the place and
live in you as hostels very cheaply and
go see the world
now's the time for you to do that now
when you're older you know I told you
guys I think about the you know
invitation to go to Nepal but I turned
down because I realized it would mean
going up and down these mountains that's
not for me right you guys could do that
but let's say you go traveling with
somebody and they're your your friend
you're either a whole bunch of you
traveled every year with them people are
going to drop out of that group they're
not gonna like that stuffing after
certainly you may be the one person who
sticks with it those of you who played
in a band so your bandmates are gonna
drop out there that could be is
interested in making music together each
one of these things if your friendship
is just based on pleasure then it's
going to last as long as the pleasure
knows same thing with utility utility is
even more fleeting if your friendship is
just a business association and you
think to yourself that you are actually
really good friends with this person
when you know as soon as you quit be
useful without a third off so you want
to be aware of this and not mix up these
different
friendship the Aristotle also talks
about some other kinds of friendship yes
he says we didn't fit these in it talks
about in equal friendships and he gives
examples father to son elder to younger
man to why ruler to some because where
we see that that sort of patriarchal
viewpoint evaluate women and elevating
that but let's stick with like the you
know parents children thing he says it's
not the same the the kind of
relationship the connection between
parents and children is not the same as
rulers of subjects now some of you may
have experienced that sort of
relationship if you have very
domineering parents Marysol says that's
a mistake there ought to actually be a
friendship between parents and children
you know what kind of pressure well
that's going to depend on their
capacities but it's going to be a money
unequal friendship until well until you
become an adult you guys are actually if
you haven't already experienced that
you're on your way to experience how
something kind of kind of interesting
which is where you become seen as fully
an adult by parents and taken seriously
not as a teenager there's not a bar or
right but is a young